shopping wahlen in deutschland dem
freistaat sachsen steht ab montag ein
harter lockdown bevor das bedeutet außer
lebensmittelgeschäften und baumärkten
bleibt der einzelhandel weitgehend dicht
viele dresdner nutzen die gunst der
letzten stunde und gehen am samstag
nochmal auf shoppingtour und ich wollte
jetzt noch mal die letzten tag nutzen
hier in sachsen vor dem lot bauen um
wirklich rest zu besorgen und ja die
geschäfte bis hin zu unterstützen
überraschend stellte ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht damit gerechnet und die holz wird
halt alles 530 auch obwohl in nrw der
doktor noch nicht beschlossen ist
erwarten die menschen auch hier das mit
dem shopping bald schluss ist sie sich
in der düsseldorfer innenstadt um
ich mache noch meinen letzten einkäufe
kurz bevor der lockdown jetzt
wahrscheinlich am montag stattfindet
freut sich noch einmal kurz die letzten
einkäufe vor sorgen für weihnachten als
ich fühle mich hier total sicher und ist
ja auch niemanden der sich irgendwie
nicht an irgendwas halten würde
also mir gefällt ich fühle mich hier
auch wohl jetzt und ich finde es uns
auch über natürliche stimmung im westen
der republik herrscht also noch nicht
überall torschlusspanik im ruhrpark in
bochum ließ sich offenbar noch ganz
entspannt einkaufen
ich fand sie sogar sehr gelassen heute
das war überhaupt nicht anstrengend
die leute sind verletzt
freuen sich alle auf die rabatte ja ich
fand es spannend ich aus voller
erwartung und angenehmen leben waren
entsprechend leer und ganz kurz setzt
wieder machen
ganz anders die stimmung in dortmund
hier war das weihnachtsshopping nicht
für jede und jeden eine freude so an
sich ist das ganz in ordnung also fühle
mich jetzt nicht verängstigt durch die
regeln oder was auch immer
also es ist ja nicht so viel los wie man
erwartet hätte und dementsprechend das
ist für mich so wie immer erwischt also
so viele menschen zu unruhig und soufian
stehen
weihnachtseinkäufe also solange die
geschäfte noch offen sind so einen
shopping wahnsinn gab es in deutschland
noch nie mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren